This course will help you improve your skills
with HTML and CSS. Popular instructor John Smilga
will teach you how to create a multi page recipe
website using just HTML and CSS. Hey, what's up,
he is john from coding addict, and welcome to
another HTML and CSS project. And this video,
we'll build a multi page food recipe site. If
you want to see the entire project in action,
just navigate to the URL HTML, CSS simply recipes
dotnet for that app, again, the URL is HTML,
CSS simply recipes dotnet will find that
up. And effectively, we've got a recipe site
with a bunch of pages. So we've got a home page,
and about page, the tags page. And then once we
click on a tag, we'll navigate to a tag template
page. We also have got recipes page, as well
as the contact page. And also if we click on a
similar recipe, we'll have a single recipe page.
Before we start setting up the project, or image
just mentioned that since it's a HTML CSS project,
there's going to be very minimal functionality. So
I'm copying and pasting, since in plenish, demo,
there are no templates or components. So
for example, if you want to display navbar,
and all pages, yes, you will have to copy and
paste, since there's no way around it. In order
to follow along with the project, you'll
need a star and probably the fastest way
to get it is by navigating to john smith without
calm again, the URL is john smith, calm, and then
look for the project page and filter by YouTube.
So check for you to project. And in here, if you
click on this button, of course, you'll navigate
to the project, the one that I just showed you,
but you're looking for the stars. So just
click on the star or the source code,
both of them lead to the same repo. And once
we get here, just look for download zip option.
And once you download the zip, of course, you
want to crack it open here. And then I'll just
drag and drop and place it on desktop, I'll use
my favorite text editor, Visual Studio code.
And I always prefer working side by side with
a browser window. So open up the browser.
I'll set them side by side. And then we'll
go over what you can find in the project.
And essentially, we've got two folders, we've got
a final one, star one. And of course in the final
is where you'll find the entire source code, just
in case you ever need a reference. And the star
is world we doing all of our work in the store,
you'll find the general structure for the project.
So I already prepared some stuff for you. Like
we have assets. So this is where you'll find
all the images, some CSS files that I'm
going to talk about a little bit later,
some empty HTML pages. So these are all
the pages that eventually will create,
as well as one lonely JavaScript file. And if
you take a look at the index HTML, you'll find
here the general setup, where essentially we've
got some link tags. So one is going to be for
favicon. Then the next one will be for normalized
CSS. We also have one for Font Awesome icons,
and one for main CSS. And if you take a look at
the main CSS, you'll find some global styles that
are used in all of my project. If you're confused
about some of this stuff, for example, why are
using normalize? And what is the benefit of global
styles, please watch my default star video where
I cover all of that in great detail. And you can
find the video link in the description. Lastly,
we're working on HTML CSS project, I prefer
extension called preview on a web, which spins
up the local web server. And as a result, once I
save the file, I can see the changes instantly.
So let me show you. So these are my extensions.
The one that I prefer using is this one, we review
on a web server. And of course, you just need to
install it. And if you want to see in a browser,
you can either right click it, and
I'll show you that in a second.
Or you can use this shortcut. So once you install
the extension, just navigate to index HTML
in the star. So of course, this is all do the
work. Now if you want to check out the final,
of course, navigate there. And then like
I said, we can right click over here,
and then choose this option. Or you can just go
for the shortcut, and I believe it was Ctrl Shift
L and once you split it up, you should see
a bridge in the browser. And like I said,
the reason why I prefer using this extension is
because every time you make some kind of changes,
you'll right away See that in the browser. So
if I go here with Hello people. And once I save
the file, check it out. Now, of course, I have the
element displayed in the browser. And then lastly,
once in a while, I want to showcase more, we've
got on a big screen as well. So therefore,
I'll navigate here. And I'll just copy and paste
this URL. So essentially, I have two browsers,
one is going to be the smart one, where it will
see the result right away. And once in a while,
I'll hop back to the big browser, just to showcase
how something looks on a big screen as well. All
right, and we're gonna kick things off with a
navbar, which has two layouts, we have a small
screen layout and a big screen layout. And on
the small screen, we can also toggle the length.
So let me make this smaller nurse is going
to be a small screen layout where of course,
we can toggle. Now, I also probably forgot to tell
you that when I'm recording, I actually zoom in.
So that's why everything looks so big.
Technically, if I go back to 100%.
Now, of course, you'll see that everything is
smaller. So don't be surprised if at some point,
your application looks a little bit different than
mine. Let me make this big. I'm gonna navigate
back to the index HTML. Again, I'm using my web
server located in the star in the index HTML.
And of course, as always, we just
need to start by adding the HTML,
we're going to do that in the following way, we're
shall remove all the code all the dummy code. And
I'll close the sidebar just so we have more
real estate. So now I have an app. And of now,
that's just my preference. And let's go with nav
element also right away, add a class of navbar.
And inside of the nav bar, I want to grow with
knives on third live. And then sort of this day,
we're gonna have two more. One is going to be for
novel links, and one is going to be for neither.
So first, let's set up the header. And again,
I'm going to use some comments here. So let's say
header. So one year, we'll place a logo with
a toggle button, and then also one for now,
of course, this is where all the links are going
to be. Now, as far as nav center, why I prefer
sticking in a number, because now we're on a
big screen, I can always make sure that the
nav content is spanning only certain with
and of course, I'll show you once we start
styling the big screen, because notice navbar
actually is going to be spanning all across,
then as far as the content, the nerve center, one
that I will always be certain with. That's why I
have that nav center inside of Napa. Now when it
comes to header, we want to place two things over
here, we have a link back to the homepage. So
basically, I'm wrapping my image in the link.
So we can always Navigate back home. Just to
show Grace, how is not going to work. Like
if I go to about page. That's the look. But if
I want to navigate back, either click on home,
or I can simply click on a logo, and I'll be back
home. And then the second thing is the toggle
button, which of course is going to have that
Font Awesome icon. So let's start with a link
for the href. We're going to go with index HTML.
And of course, this is going to make sense once
we add this navbar to different pages. Because of
course, we are already located in the index HTML,
when we'll add a class of nav logo. And then
inside of this link, let's go with IMG. And then
all the images are going to be in the assets.
And then more specifically, we have recipes one
show these ones we'll use a little bit later than
40. About for the main one, as well as logo, well,
they're just going to be located right in
the assets folder. So let's set up the path.
We're going to go with forward slash report
assets. And as far as logo one, we're just looking
for logo, SVG. And then let's add a alternative
text on our site here, simply recipes, server one,
we should see the logo on screen. And of course
we do. And after that, let's set up that button.
And this button is going to have two classes, it's
gonna have a class of btn. So this is coming from
the global styles as well as the NAB btn because
we'll do a little bit more styling. And also,
you know, let's add a type. Let's say that is
going to be equal to the button ran inside of
the button. Like I said, we're going to go with
Font Awesome icon. So we're looking for I element.
And of course, I can access these classes, because
I have the link to the font. Awesome. Notice over
here, so that's the CDN link for Font Awesome. And
then as far as the classes we're looking for FA s
and then FA and align, justify. So once I have my
element, of course, I should see my icon. Since I
do good move on to the next thing. So once we
set up the header We're here, when we want to
add a comment of lunch. And as the name already
suggests, in the nav links, we'll have a bunch
of link elements. But one of them the last one,
contract one is going to be wrapped in a div,
because it will have a little bit different
styling, not just on a big screen,
as different styling, and of course, also on a
small screen. Because of that, of course, we'll
wrap it in a div. So let's create four links,
we need to make sure that the values for the
href actually match our pages. Otherwise, it's not
gonna make sense. And I'll start with index HTML.
And as far as the text, I'm going to go with
home. But we also want to add a class of nav
link amount, I'm going to have one for about one
for tags, and one for recipes. And then make sure
the editor value actually matches the pages that
we have over here. So let me toggle the sidebar.
Man, I'll copy and paste four times, and learn as
far as the values and we're gonna go with about
HTML, when I'm looking for tags, HTML. And the
last one will be recipes, HTML, recipes, HTML,
all of them have a class of modeling, so that
stays the same. And now of course, we just want
to change these routers around as far as the text
ones. So let me select them. When I look for home,
I'll remove all of them. And we'll go
with about when we're looking for tags.
And of course, the last one little beer recipes.
Like already previously mentioned, when it comes
to contact us, it's going to be a link Yes,
it's going to navigate to the contact page.
But we'll wrap it in a div with two classes with
nav one class as well as the contact one class.
So let's say your nav link, another close contact
link. So contact hyphen link. inside of this div,
let's go with another href element. And I'll say
contact HTML. And then we'll just add a class of
button. And of course, as far as the text will go
with contact, and that should do it for the HTML.
As far as the logo I created in figma, which is
arguably the most popular web design software out
there. It's very, very easy to get started. And
you can easily find bunch of great tutorials on
how to get up and running with pigma on YouTube,
as well as Udemy. And once the bones are in place,
of course, now we can just start styling the
number mesh. And once we have the HTML in place.
Now of course, let's start styling. First, we'll
worry about the small screen layout. So first, I
want to set this one up. Don't worry about toggle
effect. And only then I'll set up the big screen
where we're going to do that by navigating to
main CSS, again, it is located in the CSS folder,
and more specifically, main CSS. And then we
have the navbar comment. So these are all the
global styles and then right off the navbar common
will start styling. And let's just start with nav
center. And eventually there's also going to be
some styles for number. But for time being though
probably not going to make sense. So I'll just add
selector for the entire navbar. First we'll start
with our center, and then you'll see what styles
we want to add to nav bar as well. So let's start
over here and I just want to go with some kind of
width. Since I want to set up this width fluid,
meaning I want to set it based on a screen size,
I'm going to go with width, and 90 view width.
So those are units. And essentially, that
just means 90% on screen with regardless
whether that's really small, or really big. And
then as far as the max width, we're going to go
over here. And then remember, I mentioned that
I'm going to be using a CSS variable for that.
And in my global styles, I have max width set
to 11 120 pixels. So that's the width I'm going
to use. Let me go back here, I'm just gonna say
half an hour friend, and then max width. And what
this means is that our content number is never
going to be bigger than 1112. That's why we have
an App Center. That's why we added Of course, max
width. Now you'll notice right now that of course
the nerve center is all the way in the left hand
side. Why? Well because we have the width bar,
we haven't set up the margin, or we haven't styled
the parent container. So we have two choices
either you go here with margin zero and auto.
So that will also always place it in the center.
Or we're gonna work with a parent container.
And in this case, we'll just say display flex,
and then justify content. We'll set it in the
center. And lastly we'll go with a line items
and I'll set it equal to center but I can tell
you right away that we won't be able to see that.
Why well because now bar doesn't have any height.
So once we add the height and is going to be on
a big screen, then we'll actually see this
property in action. If you're ever in doubt,
I highly suggest just adding the background.
So in this case, let's say you're confused,
what's happening with map center, simply go
with background and then set it equal to run.
Again, this is just going to be temporary. And
then you can do the same thing with a navbar
and trudge around and set it equal to blue. And
what you'll notice, once you go to the big screen,
so this is going to be that nav center,
it's never going to be bigger than that
1100 20 unless you use the remaining of
the number. Again, if you're ever in doubt,
two options, either you can set up the board. And
that's also something that people use. Or you can
just add the background colors. And that way you
can clearly see Okay, so this is my nerve center.
And this is the remaining of the map. Now, of
course, since I have justified con on center,
you can clearly see that Madison's are sitting
in the center of the nav bar. So now let me come
and these ones out, because they're useful. But
they're also a little bit annoying, because of
course, I don't want to look at the red color all
the time. And next, I want to go with the header.
Now of course we're styling, where we have the
logo, as well as the button. This is going to
be the case where I'll set up the height. And
I'm going to go with six REM. And what's really
interesting is that once we get to the big screen,
we'll change this height around, and effectively
we'll add the height to the entire number. But for
now, since we're just styling the small screen,
we'll go with height six arms for the header.
And then again, we want to go with display flex.
And we'll go with justify content, space between.
And essentially in here, we're just pushing these
items as far as possible, away from each other.
So notice now buttons all the way and right inside
the logo is all the way on the left hand
side. And then I also want to set them up
in the center vertically. And of course, in order
to do that, we just go with align items center. Of
course, you can use the grid for that. But it's
just always my preference to stick with flex.
If you have these straight up horizontal and
vertical layouts. Of course, once it starts to get
more complex, then grid is always a better choice.
And after that, they want to make my logo a little
bit smaller. So go with a nav header. And
then I'll target the image. And essentially,
I just want to go over 200 pixels. Now you'll
see that course our logo is a little bit smaller
than we want to go with now button. As you can
see, we already have a bunch of styles applied
because we're using that global button class. But
I just want to add a little bit different padding.
So in here, let's go with NAB btn. And then
I'm looking for padding, zero point 15.
And of course, I'm going to go with REM. And then
the same thing is going to be over here, where
we'll go with zero point 75. REM essentially in
here, just make this padding a little bit smaller,
this one a little bit bigger. Of course,
that is a choice. If you don't want that,
you don't have to apply the styles. And then
let's go for Font Awesome. Now one is, of course,
the IOM and so I'll go with navigation. And then
I'll set the font size equal to one point 25.
One point 25 RPMs. And once we have the map
button in place, when I just want to go all the
links. So of course now I'm talking about the
entire list. And as far as the nav links, I'll
set it equal to a display flex again. So display
flex hour, we're going to go with flex direction,
equal to a column. So now of course, instead
of being in one line, were stacked one on top
of each other. And then there's going
to be more styles. So out here to do,
but we'll worry about them once we start actually
toggling the links, and then we'll right away go
for that one individual link. My one has a class
of link on here. Let's go with display block.
So we'll change from being line one to display
block one, and we want to go for text align. And
I'll set it equal to center. And of course, Texas
in the center, then let's also add text transform.
And we're just going to go with capitalize. And
after that let's add a different color. And in
this case, I'm going to grow water gray one,
but I'm going to go for 900. So now of course
all the links have the same color as our text.
And then let's go for letter spacing, MT will
be equal to our CSS variable when we want to add a
padding for only add padding top bottom, padding,
one REM and then left and right zero. And also I
want to add a border on top. So let's go board top
one pixels solid, and then we're shooting for our
CSS variable. So again, I'm going to go for gray
and 500. So that's going to be my border. Then I
also want to add transition because as we'll be
hovering, I'll change the color of my link. So I'm
gonna go over here, we transition that is equal to
my CSS variable, of course, in the global styles.
And then let's just go with nav link, and then
hover. So as we're hovering, we want to change the
color, and we'll set it equal to the primary one.
And then lastly, as far as this Contact link, I
just want to change the padding again, just like
we did over here with an app button. Not to do
that, we just go here with contact, and then link,
and I'm targeting the actual link element here. So
I have the class and then I'm targeting the link.
And in here, let's go with padding. And again,
I'm going to go with zero point 15. REM, and then
one REM left and right. And once
we're done styling, the Contact link,
we're almost almost done. But before I let you
go, there's something that I want to point out.
And that is simply the fact that if you take a
look at the logo, button, you probably noticed
that even though I set up for the parent, for
the header to be aligned items in the center,
the logo, and button are not vertically in
assembling. Now first of all, let's take a
look at why is that happening. More remember,
in the index HTML, we have course a link,
and that link wraps the image. So if we're going
to go back, and again, I'm going to do that right
after header, but doesn't really matter where you
do that, I'm going to go with nav logo. And let's
do that trick. We'll go with background. And then
let's add the red one. And you'll notice that yes,
these ones, so the link, not the logo, but
the link is in one line with the button,
but not the logo that is sitting inside of going.
In order to fix that, we simply need to set our
logo to be in display flex. And then in order
to place the image in the center, we simply need
to go with align items, and then center. Again,
please keep in mind, we're talking about the logo.
So we're talking about the link, a man we set it
up as display flex and line items in the center.
So now the actual image is in the center.
Now, of course you can clearly see that are
actually in one line. So now we want to remove
the background, we don't even know more. And
once we fixed this tiny bug, we're done styling
the navbar for the small screen layout. Alright,
it looks like we're done with initial navbar CSS.
But before we worry about styling, the big screen
layout, let's quickly knock out the toggle
functionality. And as a side note, if you're
not comfortable with JavaScript, you can simply
copy and paste the code from the final directory.
And the idea is following on a small screen,
we want to hide all the strings by default.
And we'll do that by setting up the height zero in
lunch and not show them we'll create a new class
with the current height or the knowledge. And
lastly in JavaScript will toggle the nav links
by adding and removing the show links class. So
the end result should look something like this.
What if I made my screen smaller? Notice the
button. And once we click, we show the links.
And once we click one more time was LAN we hide
the links. Like I already mentioned, the plan is
following where we'll find the nav links, murders,
we have our to do before we do anything before
we set height zero, I actually want to check the
height of the nav links. So let's open up the dev
tools. We're looking for the elements. And more
specifically, we're looking forward into how links
and I can see that the height for nav links is
309 point 79 pixels. And once I know that info,
I'll create a class, I'll say show lunch. And
then we'll set up the height to be exactly that,
whatever we have right now for not once, and
in my case, I'm going to go with 310 pixels.
And once I have this height. Now of course I want
to go to now which I'm like I said by default will
hire them. So say here, height is equal to zero,
then we also need to set up the overflow hidden.
Otherwise, you can clearly see that we can still
see the links. So let's go over here or flow
hidden. We also want the transition because when
we'll be toggling actually one that toggle effect
to happen over time, not instantly. So therefore
we'll go here with transition. We'll just be
looking for the CSS variable, the transition
one. And once we have all of this in place,
we can actually test it out by just adding
and removing the class the show links one,
E and F those and then of course we'll navigate to
the JavaScript file out of functionality there as
well. So let's go to the big screen. I always find
it to be easier working there. So let's inspect,
of course, I'm looking for the nav links element
or here, and then just click on the class.
And right next to the nav links, just go
with show links. And what you'll notice,
the moment you press enter, now you can
see the links. If I remove the class,
then you can probably already guess, we won't be
able to see the links. Effectively, the only thing
we need to do right now is just navigate to the
JavaScript file. So let's go to the directory,
the JavaScript one, we're looking for app j, s.
And in here, we'll start with simple Hello World.
And then back in the index HTML, we want to set
up the script tags. So let's say your script.
And as far as the source, again, we're pointing
to the JavaScript folder, and the app js. If you
can see the hello world in a console, then of
course, we're moving in the right direction. As
far as the address, you can select the nav links
and nav button directly. But I always like to
set up a function that gets me not element and
if the element doesn't exist. So essentially,
if I get back No, then I just throw there might
seem like an overkill on a small project for
still decided to share the functionality. So in
here, we want to go with const get element. And
we'll pass in the selector. So this is going
to be either the nav links or nav button, or
whichever element you want to select. On. First,
let's go with const element. So now selected,
and I'll say document, and then query selector.
And now we pass in the selector. And you probably
already know that in vanilla j s, if there is no
element. Sure, if I pass in some kind of selector,
that doesn't point to an element, which I'll get
back to know. So I'll say here, if element exists,
only if it exists, then I'll return the
element. Otherwise, I'll throw the air.
And I'll just say throw an error. And of course,
I'll pass in some kind of message. In this case,
I'm going to go with template string, I'll
say please, double check your class names.
And we'll go there is no. And of course, now
I'm looking for that selector. And let's add
a class here. And once I have the function, of
course, we're going to test it out, where I'm
going to go with cons lunch, snom, selecting
the nav links, and all pass in the class of
nav links. If I don't see anything in the console,
then of course, we are in good shape. Now if I'll
add some class name, that doesn't point to
an element that of course will have please
double check your class names. There is no
bla bla bla class. Hopefully that is clear.
So now of course, we can set the proper class
here, copy and paste, we're going to be looking
for nav be 10. In this case, of course, we
also need to change the name here. So nav,
btn, and then DOM. And then let's just add
a event listener on the button, the click
around and then every time I click the button
will toggle the showings class. So we'll add
an remove class on the links element. So let's say
hello here now btn, van, add an event listener.
And then we'll be listening for click events. And
of course, we need to pass in a callback function.
As far as the logical simpler go with links, class
list. And toggle. So class lists is the property
on there we have toggle method. And in here, we
just need to say which class we want to toggle.
Keep in mind or in here, you do need to pass in
the.we already know that we're talking about the
class or you simply need to provide the class
value. And the moment I save, I can see that I
have no bugs in the console, which is always a
good time. And then of course, notice, as we're
clicking, we're toggling the links. So if you
want to test it out on a big screen, of course,
you can do that. And you'll clearly see that the
moment I click, I show links over here, notice how
we're again, adding this class. Of course, in this
case, we're not doing this manually. And then once
we click one more time, then we hide the links.
And before I let you go, let me just say that
I'm fully aware that we are cheating a little bit,
simply because if we change the amount of links,
or functionality is not going to work as expected,
because keep in mind that back in the main CSS,
we're actually hard coding this height value. So
of course, as we're going to be adding more links,
or removing the links, our functionality
is not going to work as expected.
If you took my JavaScript course, you probably
worked on a project where we cover the
proper toggle functionality, but since it's
not the main focus of the project, I decided to
take this route instead. Alright, and once we
have toggle function Now we're going to place
finger and close the app js. And now of course,
we'll focus on a big screen wild. So essentially,
that's the look that I'm shooting for. Once we get
to the big screen, I want all of them in one line,
links are going to be on the left hand side,
and then the contact one is going to be
all the way on the right hand side, and not user,
we just need to come up with some kind of value
for the media query. On In my case, I'm going
to go for 992. Just keep in mind that of course,
I'm zoomed in. So technically, it's
not going to happen exactly at 992.
So let's go media screen. And we'll be looking
for min width, min width. As far as the value,
like I said, I'm going to go with 992. The first
thing that I want to do is hide the knob button.
So let's just start with the class knob
btn. And we're going to go with display.
Once we get to the big screen, I don't want
to show the button. Of course, once we get
past nine to notice we don't have the button,
that's the first thing we want to accomplish.
After that, we want to go with nav bar, and we
want to set the height to be six milligrams. If
you remember, on a small screen, we now have had
or what six outcomes correct. Now in this case,
that's not what I want. Therefore, I'll go with
number. And then we'll set height to be six RPMs.
And again, if you want to check it out, of course,
background right there, and you'll see how it's
gonna look like then we want to go with a knife
center. And I want to set up display flex, why?
Because I want all of them in one line, keep in
mind that course for the links will still have to
send them up as display flex as well. Otherwise,
it's not gonna work, there will still be flex
direction column. But as far as nerve center, yes,
I want the header, I want the length in one line.
Therefore, we'll go here with now center. And
we're looking for display. And of course, we'll
set it equal to flex, then we want to align them
vertically in the center. So go with align items
center. After that, we have the now header. And
this is the case where of course we'll target that
will say nav header, I don't want the height
to be six items. So we'll just say here, auto.
So essentially, this is going to be the height
of the actual content. And then let's go with
margin. Right. So this is just going to create a
little bit of distance in between the links. Now,
if I navigate to the big screen, this is what you
should see. Now of course, we can see the links.
And this is exactly what we're going to work
on right now. Where essentially, we need to
understand that if I take a look at the links,
I set it to be equal to zero. So what happens
if I hide the links on a small screen, of
course, is exactly what I have right now,
I'm not going to be able to see them on a big
screen. So notice, if I show the links on a small
screen, I'll also see them on a big screen.
Now of course, the layout is still domestic,
don't worry about that. That's not what we focused
on. What I want to showcase is that if we hide
them on a small screen, we're not going to be able
to see them on a big screen. Why? Well, because
this height is set to zero. And in order to fix
that, we simply need to target the class first,
some nav links, we want to go with height,
auto. And now you'll notice that even though
the links are hidden on a small screen, once
we get to the big screen, we set the height,
we can see the links. Now of course, what's
more common is layout and because it is a mess,
I simply want to change my flex direction. And
I want to set it equal to row. And of course
they will be in one line, then I want to align
them in the center vertically because I have
the button and I have the ones just in case
there are some differences there. And also,
notice over here, the nav center is taking up
all of the space. And when it comes to header,
it just has its own width correct. And the same
goes for knowledge. But I want to change that
centrally. Since now center is taking all of this
space, I want my links to take up the remaining
of the space. The way we set that one up, we
just go with width, and we set it equal to 100%.
And yes, the moment nothing changed over here,
don't worry. We'll work on that a little bit
later. But now if we take a look at the links,
notice actually spanning all across so I have my
now center of our still display flex and now
the nav links are spanning all across again.
You want us to route just go with background and
red and you'll see that now. The links are picking
up the remaining space. And if I remove that
with 100. And of course, it's not the case. Now,
of course, what I want is to style those nav
links specifically, because if you remember,
there are quite a few styles coming from the
small screen, I actually want to override them.
So go with an avalanche of nontargeting at
one specific link, and I'm going to go with
padding zero, since we added some padding on a
small screen, then we want to go with war top,
sort of equal to none, when as far as the margin,
so I want some distance in between, we're going
to go with margin, right, and we'll set it
equal to one REM. And as far as the font size,
I'm going to go with non REM. And then lastly,
when it comes to that Contact link things,
I want to place it all the way on the right
hand side and simply go with margin left,
and we'll set it equal to zero. And what
you'll notice is that we have the header,
we have the lunch. And of course, the Contact
link is all the way on the right hand side.
And probably the biggest gotcha is that height
zero, we're essentially, again, on a small screen,
we set it equal to height zero, of course, once
we get to the big screen, if we're hiding those
links on a small screen, we need to show
them and therefore we set it equal to aura.
And with this in place, we're done installing
the navbar. Now of course, we can move on to
our next task. Alright. And once we're done
with the navbar, let's set up a structure for
all our pages. Now before we do that, the admin
just quickly mentioned that if you're bothered
with the small margin on a contact one, you can
simply go back and add here margin. And of course,
we're looking for margin right in this case. And
we'll consider equal to zero because of course,
all the links get this margin, right. So if we
remove it, of course, will not have that space
all the way on the right hand side. As far as the
structure, we want to set up the page class. And
then we also want to set up the footer. So this is
going to be structure for all the pages. And then
in different pages, of course, we'll add different
content, but all of them will have the navbar will
have the footer, as well as the bridge. And you'll
see once we get there. So first, let's go back to
index HTML. And then right after nav, we have an
of nav, and let's just say here, main or page or
whatever. So some kind of comment, copy and paste,
and we'll say end of main. And now let's set up a
main element. And let's add a class of page. And
then after the main one, this is where we want
to set up a for short Mingo here with Porter.
And I'm going to go with the poorer element. As
far as the class, since there might be a footer,
also, in some kind of card or something like that.
I always prefer setting it up explicitly as page
footer. But of course, this is the preference.
Technically, you can just select the footer in the
CSS, and you'll still be in good shape. And as far
as poorer. I want to go with paragraph here, then
we'll go with special HTML character. So I'm going
to go here with ampersand and then we'll say copy.
So of course, now we'll get that copyright sign.
And then I just want to set up the date. Now
for time being we'll hard code that. And then
later on video will actually set up the JavaScript
code as well. So let's go here with ID and date.
So that's what we'll use in JavaScript. Like I
said, For now, we'll just hardcode we'll say 2021.
And then right next in the span, we'll set up
another one. So still within the same paragraph,
we'll go with second span. And here, let's
class and we'll say for logo for logo. And
let's just write whatever is the logo of the
site. So in my case, it is simply recipes. But
of course, you can add different logos as well.
And then right outside of the span, but still
within the paragraph, we'll go with built by,
I'm just gonna use a shameless plug. And I'll
set up a link back to John's milk about calm. So
go with href when I want to go to the big screen,
and I'm going to be looking for John's melton.com,
I'm going to grab the href copy and paste.
And of course, now I have a link, let's just step
over here coding. So that should do it for the
HTML part for the structure for all the pages.
Now of course, we just want to swing back to the
main CSS. And I'll grab this comment one, and then
copy and paste and we'll set up one for footer as
well. Let me copy this one copy and paste and then
let's set up one for photo and you're not mature.
We're going to copy paste one more time, because
that way I can set up the next Comment as well.
And for the sake of simplicity, I'm just gonna
leave it blank. Now we'll actually start with a
footer. And only then we'll worry about the page.
And you'll see in a second why, for the time
being, what we can do on a page is just set up our
famous background red, so that we will clearly see
what we're styling. And let's just start by
targeting the page footer. So let's say here,
page footer, and I want to go with height
equals to forums. So add some kind of height,
then we'll also go with text align center. So
now all the text is going to be in the center,
then we want to add background. And let's
go with CSS variable. So in this case,
I'm looking for the value of black. And then of
course, we also want to add some kind of color.
In this case, we'll go with color. And we're
looking forward to white one. So now of course,
all the text is white, apart from the link, but
I'm noticing here that of course, I am the height.
But I'm not placing the content in the center. So
actually, a better approach is removing this text
align center, and we'll go display. And I'll set
it equal to flex. And then let's align them in
the center vertically, and also justify content,
which of course, is going to do that horizontally.
So both justify content, as well as the Align
items are set to center. Now, we still have some
default margins. And therefore we will target the
footer, and more specifically paragraph, and also
margin bottom is equal to zero. And once we have
that, I just want to add colors to the link,
as well as the logo. And in order to accomplish
that, we simply go with footer logo, then comma,
and then we'll go with page footer. And then,
of course, I want to go with color. And we'll
be looking for the primary one. So once we set
it up first, now the logo, as well as the link
this primary color. If I take a look at the
complete project, that's what I'm shooting for.
Now the next thing that I want to do is set up
the page height. Because if you notice a moment,
of course, yes, we do have the nine bar we
have the footer, but I actually want the page
to take up the remaining space. And how we can do
that, well, we can use min height. And we'll use
the calc function, because both the navbar as well
as the footer have some kind of height. And first,
let's start with some kind of width. So in here,
let's say background red, and we'll go with width.
And width always will be 90% of the screen size.
That's why we have view with units. And of course,
I also want to set up some kind of max width.
And this will be equal to my CSS variable. So
let's go over here with max width. And eventually,
what you'll notice is that the content of the page
is going to be aligned exactly like the navbar. So
if you remember, we also use the max width in the
map center. And that's why both of them will be in
one line. Now, of course, we have no content. So
you cannot see that yet. But trust me, eventually,
it's going to be there, whenever we want to go
with margin, zero and auto. So now I always place
it in the center. And then I also want to add a
little bit of padding on top. So say here, padding
top, and let's just go with two REM now of course,
you can clearly see our red box, which essentially
is going to be our page. And lastly, what we want
is set up that min height. So for all the pages,
there's always going to be this min height. I want
this to be 100%. But I want to subtract the height
of the navbar as well as the height of the footer.
So we can do that by setting up min height. When
we'll go with calc function. Let's just go with
honored view heights. So this is going to be 100%
on the screen minus. And then of course, we want
to add six hours plus the forearms, I don't want
you'll notice that regardless on screen size,
this is going to take at least 100% of the
height. Now of course, if we'll add more content,
it's going to be bigger. And you'll see that in
later pages, but at least minimum is going to be
100% minus the navbar as well as the footer.
And then before we have that all the pages,
I actually want to go to the app js, I want
to target the date element. And I just want
to showcase how we can add this dynamically. So
for the time being, let's just remove this code,
essentially, let's just remove the current year
because we're not going to be hard coding that.
And I want to swing back to App j s. And in
here right after the button. We'll go with
const date. So now we're selecting get element
and of course I'm looking for that Id missed a
date. And in here, we'll just go with constant
current year. And if you want to current year in
JavaScript, we just simply go with new date, we
invoke it. And we have functioned by the name of
get full year. So now of course, we just need
to go with date. So that's the element when
text content matter is equal to the current year.
So this way, we'll always have the current year,
we won't have to hard code this. And then lastly,
once we have this structure, I actually want to
take it, copy and paste and set it up in all
the pages. And before you get mad about it,
before you get mad about the fact that we
still need to copy and paste and all the pages,
let me just say one more time, since we're
just using straight up HTML and CSS, we don't,
we don't have any concept of templates or
components that we have in Korea. So yes,
if we have multiple pages, there's really no other
way. And of course, once we set up a structure for
all the pages, then we'll worry about index HTML.
And then one by one, we'll add code, meaning the
HTML and CSS to the rest of the pages. So once you
have the structure, since we'll use it and all the
pages, and since we have all the correct links,
whether that is for CSS, or for JavaScript, I want
to take all of us, and then one by one, I want
to add it to all the pages. Because in here, yes,
we have some boilerplate code. But essentially,
what we want is just select everything,
and then overwrite with our current code that
is coming from the index HTML. And of course,
the only thing you need to do over here is just
change the title. And since this is 404 page,
since this is an error page, we're going to go
here with error. And if you want add more text,
of course, you can do that. But in my case, I
want and then just so I can understand what is
happening, where I have the page, also add
a new one. And I'll say our page, again,
we need to do that for all the pages, we want to
do that for about contract recipes, single recipe,
back template, and tags. And of course, I'll
stop the video because I don't think it's very
useful for you to watch how I do 200 pages. But I
strongly suggest you do the same because that way,
it's going to be easier later on when we set
up the pages. And once you copy and paste our
page structure, your website should look
something like this, where all the pages,
use the navbar, you'll have the footer,
you'll also have the page with a heading one
with the name of the page. And of course, a title
that matches whatever is the file name or here.
And essentially from the navbar, you should
be able to navigate to all the pages as well
as the 404. So the 404, of course, is the one
where we need to go to the URL. And let's just
say for for HTML. And effectively, this is an
error page, if the user is looking for some kind
of resource on a server that doesn't exist. And
just to showcase how is that going to look like
in the actual dynamic application. Let me just
find here, Gatsby version three. So this is the
original project. Notice, if I'm looking
for some kind of page that doesn't exist,
let's say Users page, also in this portal for,
so that's the one that we'll set up here in the
error page. And with all this in place. Now of
course, we can keep working on a project. Next,
I actually want to work on homepage, where we have
this banner. Alright, and once we have all the
structure in place. Now of course, let's worry
about our hero. And essentially what I want is
some kind of div with a background. And for that
background, we'll use the image. And then we'll
also place a text in the center. And as far as the
HTML, we want to go to index HTML. So of course,
there's going to be our homepage. And then inside
of the main, let's just add here a comment. Let's
say that we're going to be looking for the header
element here. And let's go with the actual header
element with a class of hero. And inside of it,
we're going to go with hero container and hero
tags. And you'll see in a CSS, why we have this
nested structure. So let's go with hero container.
And then inside of that hero container, we're
gonna go with hero text. And in there we'll place
the heading one with some kind of text again,
in my case, it's going to be simply recipes. And
then right below it, we'll go with a subtitle. Now
one will be no fluff, no fluff, just the recipes.
And once we have the HTML in place now of course
we want Navigate to main CSS, open up the main CSS
here, we have already a comment. So we'll just
say your hero, I guess, before we do anything,
maybe let's just copy and paste. So we don't
worry about the next one. So copy and paste.
And then let's just say here, here, oh, and in
here, I just want to set up some kind of height
for my hero. And I guess I'm gonna go with height
of 40 view heights, essentially going to 40%
of the screen. So let's go with height. And
once we have that, let's add that in background.
So let's go over here with background URL. And
we'll be looking for the image. And in this case,
I'm looking in the assets. And we'll go with
main jpg. But of course, we want to place it
in the center, we want to make sure it covers
everything. And also there's no repetition,
of course, we can do it long way. Or there's
also a shortcut, where we go and center cover,
and then we set it equal to no repeat. So once
we do that, of course, we should see the image.
Now what I want is to add a border radius. So I
want around the edges. And I also want to add a
little bit of margin in the bottom. So let's
go here with margin bottom on assert equal to
two RMS. And also I want to add that border
radius. So let's just go with border radius,
and set it equal to our border radius
global property. Now, in order to set up
Look, where I have a text right in the center, and
as you notice, here, the background is actually
a little bit darker. So there's some kind of
overlay on image will actually set this one as
position relative position relative, and
then the hero center. So this enclosing div,
this is where all set up position absolute. And
then we'll use this player flex to place a text
in the center. So let's keep scrolling. And we're
gonna go with hero container. And like I said,
we're gonna go with position absolute. And since
the parent is position log, Now, of course,
we're setting up everything based on a parent.
And then here, I just want to have a width 100%,
height, all 100%. And then let's just set up
top and left to be equal to zero. So top left,
both are equal to zero. And once we have all of
this in place, Now, of course, let's add that
overlay. And we do that by going with background.
And then we're looking for RGBA. And I'm just
gonna go with 000 0.4. So RGBA. Now, this gives
me 0.04. That's not what I want. So essentially,
notice how the background right now is darker.
So we added the overlay on top of the image.
And of course, if we go really dark, then of
course, there's going to be hard to see the image.
So therefore, I go here with RGB. And as a result,
I can nicely control this color. So the darker
you'll go here, of course, the darker the overlay
is going to be. And the reason why we want to set
that up, is because if we don't do that, then of
course with white text, it is going to be hard
to see the text. That's why we want to set up the
image, we want to add the overlay, and we want to
add some dark color to it. And then we'll make
the text white. So right after the background,
we can probably go with border radius, since at
the moment, our image has the border radius, but
not the container. So let's go with border radius,
and set it equal to the border radius property.
And then if I want to place the text in the
center, we want to go with display flex align
items center. So now it's going to be for
vertical, just for content is going to be for
horizontal center. And then we want to target the
Hero Packs. So that's going to be a div inside of
that container. So here are tags. And let's just
set up text align center, because you notice,
even though the hero text is in the center, the
actual text inside of it is not before we go
text align, and we set it equal to centers.
Now, of course, everything is in the center.
And let's also add that white color. So let's
go with our CSS variable. And of course, the
name is white. And then the very last thing that
I want to add is the media query for 768 pixels.
And once we get to that screen size, I want to
make the font size for heading one for RPMs and
set the margin bottom to be equal to zero. From
here, let's go with media screen. And of course,
we're looking for some kind of value. In this
case, I'm going to grow with men with 768 pixels.
And once we get to the screen size, like I said,
we're going to go with hero text and how Everyone,
let's just go with font size for RPMs. And
then let's set up the margin bottom to be
equal to zero. And once we have everything in
place, let's navigate here, this is going to be
the look on a big screen. And if we make this
smaller, of course, this is going to be the
look on my screen. Now, as always, I'm massively
zoomed in. So technically, if you take a look at
the small screen, it's going to look something
like this. And once we have our here on place,
now of course, we can focus on our recipes,
where we'll have two column layout. On one side,
we'll have tags. And then on the other side, we'll
have the cards beautiful. With our hair out of the
way. Now let's tackle the big beast, the recipes
layout, where we've got a two column layout with
tags in one column, and cards in the other. Now,
since we'll reuse this layout in multiple pages,
please take your time. And don't rush with this
one. Better to take more time right now than chase
some silly spelling errors later on from my part,
I'll probably be even more annoying than usual,
by repeating the same things over and over. Since
in here we have the nested layout. So it can get
tricky. And therefore I think it's important that
I basically keep repeating the same thing. And
we'll also split this one into multiple videos,
just so we can build everything step by step.
The good news is, once we're done with the
recipes, it's pretty much smooth sailing from here
on out. And effectively, we want to go back to the
index HTML, of course, we're looking for the main
and you want to place this one in the main. So
not outside of main not inside of the footer,
you still want to place it in the main and
therefore allowed bunch of comments here
as well. Again, we will reuse this one. So it's
much easier if you have clear comments where the
next section starts, or element. And hopefully
you get the gist. So we'll go here with end of
error. And we'll have another set of comments.
And let's just go with recipes container
container. I'll do it over here as well. And let's
just say endof love recipes container. And we're
going to go with section with a class of recipes,
container section, recipes, container, inside of
the container will have two major things. We'll
have a tags container. So I'm talking about verse
column over here. So this is gonna be our tags.
And then we'll have recipes cards. And of course,
there's going to be more content. But for now,
let's just set up those main elements. And again,
we'll place a bunch of comments, let's say tag
container. And we'll copy and paste course, on
here, we'll say tag container. And as far as the
tags, we'll just go with div with a class of tags
container. So if you want, maybe let's add an
s here as well, just so it makes a little more
sense. And then we have a recipes list. So these
are going to be those cards. And in this case,
I think I can just copy and paste, we'll just
change things around where I want to select
all the tags here. And let's say recipes. And
instead of container, this is going to be a list.
So let's say here. So that's going to be the
structure for this container, recipes container,
run tags container, where we'll have the
tags. Here, of course, we'll have the cards,
the recipe cards. And now one by one, let's add
more content. As far as the recipes container,
we're going to have 104 with a text of recipes.
And then also have a div with a class of
tags list. And essentially in here, I'm
just gonna have lunch. Now, since again,
this is HTML and CSS project will simply navigate
through the page to the tag template page
will display these recipes when you're talking
about the dynamic project one, but we set it up in
Gatsby. Of course, in here we navigate to the
tag, of course, we display that one specific or
multiple recipes that are associated with
that tag. Keep in mind that in this case,
of course, it's not going to be dynamic, we'll
just have one page and we'll navigate there,
content will always be the same. But when it comes
to dynamic project, of course, you'll click on a
tag and then you only display the recipes that are
associated with that tag. And hopefully you can
already see when it comes to layout, it resembles
a lot to what we have here in recipes list.
So this is what I'm talking about where we
will reuse this layout. Some parts of this
layout quite heavily Around the project. So let's
make sure that we set up everything correctly.
So back in the index HTML tags contain an array of
heading four. And in here, I want to go with tags
list. And essentially, these are just going to
be linked to the tag template page, then they're
not going to be dynamic, all them will point
to the same page. And essentially in there,
we'll just have static content. And as far as
the href, we want to go with that template HTML.
And here, let's just add some different values.
So I'm going to go with beef. And I'll say one.
So what I'm trying to say here is that there's one
recipe that has the tag of beef. And of course,
we'll just copy and paste and change these routers
around. So for breakfast, we'll go with two
than four carrots, we'll go with three carrots,
we'll go with three. And here, of course,
we'll have the generic one, the food one, which
is for, and again, not to be redundant, but in a
normal project, of course, versus coming from the
database. So this info is coming from database.
And it changes it is dynamic, the more items you
add course, you'll display different info in here,
just HTML and CSS project. So of course, we're
just hard coding. When it comes to recipes list,
we want to set up those guards. So we're done
with tags container should look something like
this. I'm back in the recipes list, we want to
set another comment, we'll go with single recipe.
So this is going to be that card. And we'll
copy and paste. So say and have single recipe.
And in here, I want to go with link. Now this link
is going to go to single recipe page. Essentially,
this page probably is going to be the last we
set up because there's also quite a bit of work
over there. But the idea is that this goes to
the tag page. But then this one goes to that
single recipe, whatever it is, again, in our case,
it's going to be hard coded. So if you take a look
all the time display the same info here. But in
general, when you have dynamic product, of course,
you display a different recipe. Hopefully that
is clear. As far as the href will go with single
recipe HTML, right away out of class here, have a
recipe. And inside of it, we want to go with image
as far as the source while it's going to be in
the assets. And we'll start with recipe one,
then two, I believe we'll have four. So you can
already guess that, of course being the assets,
we have recipes folder. And in there, I have
recipe one, recipe two, three, and four.
So let's start with the first one. So we're gonna
we have here a image tag. Now let me close the
sidebar. And we're going to be looking in the
assets, and then more specifically the recipes.
And then in there we have recipe one,
jpg. Now as far as the alternative,
not just say food. And I also want to right away
add classes. So the generic IMG class, remember,
was set in global styles, as well as recipe.
ru IMG master class, I want to learn right
after my image. Let me close this one. And right
after my image, let me go with the heading five.
And I'm going to go with some kind of text. Let
me just see. So I'm going to go with this one. And
I'm also going to go with prep time and cook
time. So I'm going to set up a paragraph
with the text of prep. And again, in
this case, we're hard coding, of course,
we're going to go with 15 minutes of a vertical
bar. And of course, we'll go with cook. This is
going to be equal to five minutes. Let me save
it, let me take a look. That should be the look
on a big page. Okay, looks about right. And
now we simply want to copy and paste this one
and just change the heading five. So I'll leave
the paragraph exactly the same. But since I'm
going to be changing the pictures, I'll also
change the text over here. And if you want to see
the final text, just navigate to complete project
and of course, this is what we're shooting for.
So these are the titles of our recipes. So let me
just take here where I have the starting comment
and select everything, including the admin comment
and now of course we want to copy and paste three
times so 123 and now the only thing left to do
is scroll up. Okay, that's our first recipe.
And we will look for the next one, we'll just
change the image. Now of course this is going
to be recipe number two. And as far as the
text, these are going to be Greek ribs, ribs
and let me just save it so I can see Yep, that
looks about right, then we have vegetable soup.
And that is going to be recipe number three. And
of course, I'll change the text here as well.
And the last one will be banana pancakes. And
of course, we want to change the image as well.
So in this case, we're looking for recipe number
four. So if I take a look at the big screen should
look something like this. Of course, we have
the recipes. So these are going to be our tags.
And then we have those four recipe cards.
Wonderful. We're actually done with HTML.
So now let's navigate to main CSS. And of
course, let's set up the styles. Like always,
we'll start with the small screen, of course,
and then we'll worry about the big screen layout,
I have my comment here. Let me copy and paste. And
here, I'll just write recipes. And then in order
to help us, I'll add some borders, again, just so
we have an understanding of what's happening. So
in here, let's go with a recipes container. So
that's gonna be that main container. And here,
we'll go with display grid. And if you remember,
by default, is going to be a one column layout.
So that's exactly what I want on a small screen.
But eventually, keep in mind that this is going to
be a two column layout. Correct. So we might
as well set up the gap right now for both
for rows, as well as the columns. Again, I'm
talking about the parent container, where I have
the recipes and the cards. And therefore, I'll
go with gap here. And I'll say, to REM, and we'll
set it up as one REM again, at the moment, we'll
only use one, because we have one Commonwealth.
But then eventually, once we have two columns,
essentially, once we set up the meter queer,
of course, then we'll use both of the values are
we're about as clear workers, in order to help us
more just go with two pixels, solid, and red, just
so we can see what's happening. So that's gonna be
my main container. When we want to go with tags
container gun, that is for tags, tags container.
And essentially, we want to set up
right away board just so we can see what
is happening. So what we're styling. And in this
case, I'm going to go with below. And once I save,
I should see over here that that is my
tags container. And as far as the styles,
I actually want to place it all the way at
the bottom. So I want to change the order.
Notice over here in the index HTML, what do I
have first, of course, I have the tags. Correct,
I have my dark container. And only then I have
the recipes list. And as I noted, may just change
this one as well. So it's not going to be recipes
container will go with recipes lists, so and of
recipes list, just so we have a little bit more
clarity on what I'm trying to do on a small screen
is to actually change the order. So notice here,
I have the hero first. And then I have the cards.
And all the way in the bottom, I have
the recipes. I mean, it's not a big deal,
you can technically keep it at the top, but
it's actually my preference to change the order.
And if you remember, by default, all of them
have order of zero. So if you add order of one,
you'll notice that the recipes are going to
be all the way in the bottom. So essentially,
we have the recipes list still with order
zero, and we just change the order over here.
Now of course, once we get to the big
screen, we'll change it back again. But
that's a different scenario, than we want to go
with display flex, and flex direction column.
Now again, keep in mind that I'm talking about
the parent container for the heading for as well
as the lunch. So for both of them. Now, when it
comes to links, there's going to be another nested
layout. But we'll worry about that one a little
bit later. So let's just say here, display flex,
then we want to go with flex direction, we're
going to be looking for the column. Eventually,
we want to set up the button in the bottom
as well. And we'll set it equal to three REM,
so should look something like this, then we
want to go with a recipes list. And then we'll
swing back to the tags. So let's go over here
with a recipes list. And again, by default,
this is going to be a one column layout. And
we'll do that just by setting up display grid.
And then we'll right away set up the gap of qR
yams and one REM and again, this is going to
be the same as with the main container where since
we have one column layout, of course, we're not at
the moment using both values. But how the recipe
list eventually is going to look like. Well,
it's going to be a three column layout. Correct.
So therefore i right away and that got property
with both of the values. And also I want to do
the same thing where I'll add the padding bottom
equal to three REM when we want to swing back The
tags. So I set up pretty much the major styles
for the recipes list. Now I want to worry about
the tags. First, me scroll down just so you can
see what's happening. We're going to go with tags
container, when we're looking for heading for,
of course, and we'll add a little bit of margin
in the bottom. So say here 0.5 RPMs. And as far as
the font word was changed around, and let's set
it equal to 500. After that, I want to go with
entire list course, I'm talking about the actual
tags list, and I'll make the screen size bigger
just because I have zoomed in. Otherwise, it's
gonna look funky. And we're gonna go tags list.
And in here, we want to go with display grid,
and right away, set it up as a three column
layout. So let's say grid, template columns. And
we're looking for one fraction, one fraction,
and one fraction. Again, keep in mind that this is
going to be a small screen layout. Once we get to
the big screen, of course, we'll set it back to
one column while running, we want to style the
actual link. So let's say over here, tags list.
And of course, the moving forward link element. As
far as the text transformation, we'll capitalize
it when we want to set them up as display block.
And after that, we want to set up the color. And
I'm going to go with my gray 500 here. And also
I'll add transition because there's going to be a
hover effect. So transition. As far as hovering,
let me just speed this up by copying. Then
I'll say hover. And as we're hovering,
I'm just going to change it to primary. So
again, covering both the color, and instead of
gray. Let's go with primary. Once we save,
we should see that as we're hovering, notice,
of course, we're changing the color of the link,
run, we want to go and style the recipe. Now what
is the recipe? Well, that is going to be our
card. So we're pretty much done with a tags,
of course, apart from the big screen, and
therefore I'll still leave those borders,
I'll remove them at the very, very end. And you're
not actually with me look for the recipes list.
And let me add the border here as well. Because
I think it's gonna be very helpful later. So
let's say here, green, let's say that one on
your course, we're going to see where we have
our columns. And like I said, we're gonna target
the recipe. So that's going to be the entire card
recipe here. And remember, it was a link. So start
with display block. And then once we set this up,
now, of course, I want to target the image. So
each card has the image. So let's target it,
let's say recipe. And I believe
the class 40 image was recipe IMG.
And I'll set up the height, and I'll go 15 REM
work. So Vern, all right away a border radius.
Look for our CSS variable for that course,
border radius. And as far as the margin, well,
we're just set up margin bottom one, REM,
we save that one. And then we want to go
with a recipe and heading five. So of course,
it's going to be the title, and also want to
style the paragraph. And then we're pretty much
done with a small screen. So let's go over here,
let's say recipe. And heading five, like I
said, we're looking for margin bottom zero,
then I want to make the line height smaller. So
go with one, if you remember in global styles,
of course, by default, it was bigger. And then as
far as the color, let's go with color. And we're
gonna go with gray 700. So it's not going to be as
dark as the rest of our text, it's going to be a
little bit lighter. And then also we have one for
the paragraph. So let's say your recipe paragraph.
And basically what we're looking for is margin
bottom to be zero because there is some margin as
a default. And the same thing, line height will be
equal to one. And that's usually the case when I'm
dealing with some kind of cards because you don't
want those massive line heights around what's also
add right away margin top to be 0.5 RPMs. Just so
we get a little bit of space. As far as the color,
I'm going to go with gray, but I'm looking for
500. So I'll just copy this one, just so we can
save a little bit of time. And then I also want to
set up the letter spacing. So the letter spacing,
and we're looking forward to CSS variable. There
it is. With this in place, we're actually done
styling the small screen layout. Now of course,
we just need to focus on multiple media queries.
Wonderful. Our small screen looks pretty good,
apart from those borders, which of course will
remove a little bit later. So now let's focus
on the multiple screen sizes. And of course,
we'll do that setting up the media queries. So
let me go here with media screen And I believe
we'll have three of them. So right away, set
them up. And then we'll just worry about the
code inside of them. So let's just go with
576 pixels. And then we want to copy and
paste this one two times. And then as far
as the values, one is going to be for 992.
Online, last one will be for 1200 pixels. So we
set this one up. And inside of the first one,
we want to go with recipes list. So this is the
actual list where we have the cards. Keep that in
mind, I'm not talking about the container, talking
about the recipes list where we have the cards,
and I want to set it up as two column layout. So
let's go over here with recipes list. And we want
to go with grid template columns. And we'll set
it up as one fraction, one fraction. Now keep in
mind that if we scroll up, if we take a look at
the recipe list, it is already a display grid.
Correct. So therefore, I can right away, set
up that column. Well, I also like to set up
my images a little bit more, once they're side
by side. So on a small screen, I mean, 15 remc,
is pretty good. But once actually the screen size
gets a little bit bigger meaning starting with
576. Once I have to come Well, actually, it makes
a little bit more sense to go with a recipe.
And then IMG, at least in my opinion, of course
you don't have to but in my opinion, I always
go with 10 RPMs. Basically, I said them smaller,
maybe sometimes bigger than than REM. So hopefully
you get the gist. So now let me navigate here to
the big screen just to showcase what's happening.
So I'll make this one on over here. So
this is going to be our one column layout.
And then once we get to the 576 course, this
is going to be the look. So now we have that
two column layout. Hopefully that is clear. Now
we can focus on 992. Now at 992 will actually
change the layout for the entire container, where
we have the tags, as well as this recipe list.
And we will do that, of course, we will look
for our media query. that's step number one.
And we're looking for recipes and container.
Now again, it is already in display grid.
Correct, starting with a small screen. So the
only thing we really need to do is come up
with values for the columns. And in my case, I
went with 200 pixels. So that's for the tags.
That's the width of my first column, and then one
fraction, basically to take up the remaining space
for the recipe list. And as far as the recipes
list, well, I have already a grid template column
set to one fraction, one fraction, so I don't
need to worry about that. The only thing that
I want to set up here, and maybe I'll style the
paragraph a little bit differently as well. But
as far as the tags container, I want to go with
or zero. Remember, on a small screen, what was the
order? It was one. And what was the result? Well,
the result was that tags are all doing the bottom
correct. So they're after the recipes list. Now
of course, once we get to 992, I want this look,
I want actually both of them side by side,
like this. So I need to place it back where
it belongs. And of course, I can do that with
order of zero. So let's go with tags. And then
list let's set up or I'm sorry, not tagged with
my bad. So tags container first, and we'll go with
or, and of course it's going to be zero.
And then as far as the tags list, of course,
we have three column layout on a small screen. But
it's got something we want over here, where's No,
we want one column layout, because now
of course, they will be side by side.
Now how we can achieve that all we can go to tags
list and remember it is already display grid,
it already has the column layouts, we simply need
to change it, we need to go with grid template
columns and set it up as one fraction. And lastly,
as far as the recipe, I actually want to go
with Paragraph Font size to be zero point 85.
REM, so you can place it at the very end or
after the recipe doesn't really matter. We'll go
with recipe paragraph. And let's just go with font
size. And like I said, we're going to be looking
for 0.5 REM. Let's save it. And let's take a look.
And we can clearly see that this is our main
container with a red border. And then of course
we have blueboard order recipes, meaning for the
tags I'm sorry, and the green one for recipes.
And as you can see, once we have a smaller screen,
then of course we have this layout. And once we're
good over here beautiful Now we have two column
layout. And lastly, once we get to 1200 pixels,
the only thing I really want to do here is make
the recipes list, a three column layout. So let
me swing back. And we'll keep on scrolling. And
of course, at 1200 pixels, will set up our recipes
list to be a grid template columns. And of course,
I'm looking for three column layout. So I'm
gonna go with one fraction, one fraction and one
fraction. And yes, I'm fully aware. And of course,
we can write the repeat and all that. But in
this case, I just thought that it's going to
be quicker if I go with one fraction. And then
as far as the font size for the heading five, I
want to set it up to be one point 15. REM. So I'm
looking for a recipe. And since I already have for
the paragraph, I might as well copy and paste. And
essentially, we want to go with heading five here,
believe it was hitting five, and then we'll go
with 1.1 point 15 RMS, let's save that one. And
I need to navigate back to the homepage here. Now
let's take a look at our big screen layout. So
essentially, once our screen gets bigger, bigger,
bigger, bigger van, of course, we arrived at the
three comwell. Again, this is going to be the look
on a small screen, where we have recipes list.
First of all, and we have the tags van once we get
to the 576 we have two column layout for recipes
list. Then once we get to 992, we have two column
layout for the entire container. And we still have
these two columns over here for the recipes
list. And then once we get to the big screen,
Wallah course. Now we have two column layout. Here
we have three column layout. So now of course, the
only thing really left is to remove those borders.
So we have recipes list, we have tags container,
of course, we have the recipes container. And
with this in place, we have tackled the big beast,
congratulations. And of course, we can move on
to our next step. Not bad, not bad. Essentially,
we're done with our own page. So now let's knock
out the other pages as well. We'll start with the
easy ones first, like error and recipes, and
eventually work on more complex ones as well.
And this video, I want to complete three pages,
or a page or recipes page. template page. Let's
start with an error. I know I already said this
before. But essentially the 404 error page is if
the server cannot find the resource in the Gatsby
project is going to look something like this.
Or again, we go with a domain and then we say
error. And of course that's going to spit back
the error page. And actually, if you deploy
this project, really simple recipes, one,
it's going to work the same way. So even the HTML
and CSS one on natla phi, if you're looking for
some kind of pressure, there's an existence, we
have the 404 course we'll get back this result.
Now in our local development, that's not going to
happen because the extension is not that smart. So
in order to see the page, of course, we'll have
to do that manually. The way we're going to do
that in the project is following we were first
on a big screen, let's just type 404. html, Okay,
looks about right. And then we want to do
the same thing. So let me grab the URL,
and just copy and paste and set it up on a small
screen as well. So let me select everything.
And then I'm looking for 404. So this is
how it's gonna look like. Now when it comes
to actual code course we want to navigate to
404. html course this is going to be our basic
structure for all the pages. And for the error
page, we simply want to add one more class here,
since we'll add a little bit more styles. And
let's say here are on hyphen page. And then as
far as the content will go here with section and
then serve section. Let's go with heading one,
let's say error. And then lastly, let's go with
heading three, and also a page not on font.
So resave it over here. And now of course
we just want to go back to main CSS.
Again, we're looking for our comment, we want to
make sure that we have for the next one. on here,
I'll just say error as far as the code.
Essentially what we're looking for
is that class of error page error page. And we'll
go with text align, text align, center, like so.
And of course, we also want to add a little bit
of padding to the top amount will be equal to
five arms. And when it comes to a heading one,
let's just go with error page on heading one
and let's go with font size and RPMs. And you
know, I messed up a little bit more in the 404, we
actually want to go with 404, the numbers marked
the text of her. And of course, we have our page.
And once that is done with me just navigate back.
And in this case, we're looking for recipes page,
again, in the navbar. recipes page. And the same
is going to be on a big screen where we want to go
to the recipes page. And what's really cool, we
already have all the code for it. And you know,
get the code over here, take a look at the
project. So this is our homepage, correct. We have
the hero as well as the recipes layout. Now, what
do you think is going to be in recipes? Well, is
going to be pretty much the same page without the
hero. And again, this is the case where of course,
normally, this is some kind of template, or this
is a component where you just pass in the data.
So you don't have to repeat yourself. But
like I have already said million times,
since we're working with just HTML and CSS. Yes,
we will have to copy and paste. Now, of course,
let me go back to my project. And I'm looking for
the index HTML. This is the reason why I added so
many comments over here, because we definitely
don't want to mess this up. So we have main over
here, correct with a class of page, then we have
the hero so we can actually collapse this one. And
what we're looking for is this entire container.
Now there's going to be few more instances where
we'll just be looking for recipes list. This
is not the case, in the recipes page, you want
to take the whole thing. So therefore I have
these comments where recipes container, so copy
everything with the comment of recipes container,
and then and of recipes container. That's what
you're looking for, not the main. Now that stays
over here. But the recipes container. Yeah,
take the whole thing, copy. And now of course, I
want to navigate to recipes, HTML, that's my page,
we keep on scrolling. And where we have the
page, the main one, we simply want to dump
our recipes layout. So we just paste our code over
here. Let me save recipes, HTML, as well as the
index one. And now in our project, if we take a
look, Wallah, we have a recipes page down. So this
is going to be our home page. And this is going
to be our recipes page. And lastly, In this video,
I want to work on tag template, which also is
going to look very, very familiar. Because if we
take a look at complete project, either to Gatsby
one, or just HTML and CSS, which you'll notice,
but if we navigate to a tag bridge, what do we
have over here, we have some kind of hard coded
value, which of course, again, is not going to
be the case in dynamic project. So this value
will change based on the tag. Now in this case,
of course, that's not the case will always have
this beef. And then what do you see over here?
It looks like a list. Correct? Now, where do
you think his list is coming from over here.
So that's why we set up the CSS in such a way
where it doesn't really matter where we're placing
that list, gonna have one column where I'll put on
a small screen, and two column layout on a bigger
screen. And then once we get to the big screen,
it's gonna be a three column world. And in order
to set that up, we simply go and look for the
tag template, because remember, index HTML, or in
the recipes now as well, when we're talking about
those tags links, where do they navigate back
template correct. So therefore, we'll look for
tag template. And then again, we have the main
one, a class of page. Now, of course, we just
want to change it around a little bit, where
we'll start by setting up a enclosing div. And
we're simply doing that because I want to place
the heading for on top of rest of the content. And
we're going to go with beef. So again, we're hard
coding some kind of value, in this case, beef. And
now what you want is grab the recipes list from
the index HTML. And I'm not going to repeat this
whole spiel about why we're copying pasting,
because I think I already have mentioned this
way too many times during the project. So we're
looking for recipes list, not the container.
We're looking for recipes list. Take a look at
the comment and look for the end one as well.
So we're looking for and have on here probably
muster up, or no, sorry, I muster up right now
because I was looking for different comment.
Again, we're looking for recipes was my bad.
I mixed it up with the recipes container and the
recipes list. That's the endpoint. We copy this
one and by In the tag template, copy and paste,
and congratulations, we have three pages out of
the way. So now of course, we have the home page,
we have the recipes, we have 404. If we click on
one of the tags, whether in the recipes page, or
in the home page, where are we going to navigate,
we're going to navigate to a tag template, where
it will display the bag and list of recipes,
which again normally would point to the recipes
that are associated with that tag. And of course,
you will be setting this up dynamically normally.
But if we're just worried about HTML and CSS,
we have three pages out of the way. And
of course, we can focus on next pages.
Nice. And next, I want to work on the about page,
where effectively we'll have two column layout
for the info, as well as the picture. And then
here at the bottom. Again, we're going to use
a list. So technically, these would be some
featured recipes that you want to display. Again,
normally, this is going to be dynamic, you'll
just pass in which recipes you want to showcase
point and Rockers, we'll just use our recipes
list, same one, we used in tag template, this
one over here. Now in this case, or we only want
to pass in three. So we're in the tag template,
we set up four parameters goes, we'll just go with
three. And effectively, we will reuse that list
few more times throughout the project. The setup
is going to be exactly the same where again,
looking for about HTML, I have my page. So I do
have the structure. And here let's set up those
recipes first, and navigate here to the about page
as well. So we can see right away. And once we set
up those featured recipes, so the recipe list,
then we'll worry about the rest of the content.
Inside of the page, we want to go with section.
And then let's add a bout page. So this is where
the info as well as the photo are going to be
located. And then we want to go with another
section. And then let's just call this featured,
recipes, recipes. And actually don't think that
there are any styles with it, but more just on the
section with this class. And then inside of it,
we want to go with heading five. And we're
looking for a featured title. And I'm sorry, this
is a class. So it's a featured title. The only
reason why I'm adding here this class is because
I want to place the text in the center. And again,
technically, we can use this feature recipes. But
if I remember correctly, the heading five
was already in the car. So that's why I
just went here with this class. Again, long
story short, basically, we'll set this one
in the center. And then as far as the text logist,
right look at this awesome source. And right
below it. This is where we want to place those
recipes. So let's go back to index HTML. Again,
we're looking forward to recipes list. Same deal,
man. This goes Of course, eventually we'll remove
one of the cards placed in my setup. But if you
want, of course, you can keep all four. So we
copy and paste the list. We're looking for
what we were looking for about HTML correct.
Got a little bit last order. And then right after
the heading five. So within featured recipes, we
want to copy and paste and like I said, Margot's,
I'll remove one of them. So I'll remove the last
recipe. And once we save, of course, we right away
have our nice layout, like I previously mentioned,
effectively for this one for 205, I just want
to place it in the center. So let's quickly go
to CSS. And we're looking for feature title, I
believe, featured. And we're looking for title.
And we're simply want to go text align center.
Now of course, it's going to be in the center
without the recipes less part. Now of course,
we just want to add that info, which is going
to be here in the About page. We also want to add
a photo. So let's set that one up. And in here we
want to go with article. So this is where the info
is going to be located. And then right below it,
we're going to go with image. And in this case,
we're looking in the assets. More specifically,
we're looking for the about one and nine as
far as the alternative. I'll just say pouring
salt. And we'll also add few more classes to
image. Those are following we'll go with our IMG,
so the global one, as well as about IMG. Now when
it comes to info, we're looking for Heading Two.
We'll just type some kind of text and you're
not in this case just so we can speed this
one up. Look for this project already. Other
one, basically just copy and paste the text,
there's really no point to return that from
the scratch. And essentially, I got this text,
I believe from the hipster ipsum, which is
my favorite place to get lorem ipsum text,
effectively the dummy text. And we want to go
here with the first paragraph. So there will
be two paragraphs. And I'm just getting the text
over here, if you want, you can simply type Lorem,
and then whatever amount of characters, so you can
go here with Lorem. And then let's say 20, or 10,
or whatever. Now in my case, since I liked that
text better, we're just going to copy and paste.
That's my first paragraph. And then of
course, we're looking for a second one.
And at the very, very, very bottom, also have
the button. So it's here button class will be
btn. And we want or you're not sure is going to
be a link, my button shows me remove my apologies,
we're going to go with link, this is going to be
to contact HTML, when we want to add a class of
btn. And let's add a contact. And since we have
already global class for to beat him, that's why
we have to look. And now of course, we want to
swing back to main CSS, and we just want to apply
few styles to about page, I'm just gonna keep this
one on the bottom. Because I like to keep things
organized that way, but of course, you're gonna
leave it at the top as well. We're gonna go with
about page, we're looking forward to heading two.
So that's that main heading with dummy text. So
both page heading Q and hero, say text transform,
set equal to none. And there's no transformation
because for all the headings, we have that base
transformation, then as far as the font size, I'll
go with bold, so I'll make it a little bit bolder.
And then in here, let's also set up about page.
Now, of course, I'm talking about that section.
And first, I want to go with display grid,
display grid. And again, by default is going to be
that one column layout. But that doesn't stop me
from setting up the gap. Correct. So again, I have
two arms, and forearms. So this one, of course,
is going to be for my row. And then this one will
be for my columns. And again, the morning we have
one column, so it doesn't really matter. And then
we also want to set up right away some kind of
padding here. Let's go with padding bottom, three
REM, so that's going to be added to this entire
thing. So now of course we have distance between
section, the about page, our featured recipes.
And then we also want to target right away
the image. As far as the about the image,
we have the class correct. So let's go with
about half an IMG. And we're looking for border
radius. And we use our CSS variable for that.
As far as the height, well, let's set it up as
300 pixels. Now, of course, the height is a little
bit smaller. And then we also want to of course,
go with some kind of media query because on a
bigger screen, we'll have a two column world.
So let's set up a meteor screen. As far as the
size, let's go with men with macros. Again,
I went with 992. That was just my preference. And
we'll target the about page, setup grid template
columns, grid template columns as one fraction
and one fraction. So we have two column layout.
And then when it comes to rows, I'm going to go
with 400 pixels. Now keep something in mind where
we will have only one row. And essentially what
I'm doing, I'm setting up the height for my row,
and then I'll use the height for the image
and I'll set it equal to 100%. So effectively,
as a result, my image is going to be the height
of my arrow. So let's try it out over here. We'll
say grid template rows, and we're looking for
400 pixels. And then of course in here we'll
go with a line items, and we'll placing it in the
center. And I'll comment this one out in a second
just so we can see why we're adding that one. And
let's go with our about IMG and then here we'll
go with height. And like I said, we're gonna go
with 100%. So now what happens on a small screen
while this look so once I make my screen size
smaller is going to look something like this.
And once we get to 992 we have this two column
layout, and then image is the height of my row.
And since text is smaller, now of course we're
placing it in the center. Now if I'll comment
this one out, you'll notice that text is all the
way at the top. So let me put it back in there.
And of course we have the about page completed
as well. All right, as far as the next step,
we want to go to contact page. And of course,
tile this sucker. Practically here, where I'm
saying feature of recipes are, we already know
where to get them. The moment we have them already
in the about a man when it comes to form. I
mean, most of it is already in a global CSS.
So we should be done with this in no time.
Now, at the moment, of course, in the contact,
this is all I have a text with contact page.
And of course, we'll start in the contact HTML.
That's what we're looking for. And like I said,
since I want to simplify this, first, we'll go to
about HTML. And we're looking for those featured
recipes. So take this section, the featured one,
and just copy and paste and place it in
the contact page. So take all this code,
navigate back to contact HTML. And in here, we'll
have two sections. One is going to be for dot
info, as well as the form. Now let me close the
sidebar. So let's start with that section. Let's
set up a section with a class of contact, and
then hyphen, container. And right after it, we'll
copy and paste our featured ones. So this is what
you should see on a screen, the featured recipes.
And of course, we just need to navigate up where
we have the actual container, the contract one,
as far as the HTML, I mean, there's
not much, there's some headings,
some paragraphs, like I keep saying form
as well. And we'll start with an article.
So the article is gonna have some kind of
class. And we're gonna go with contact info.
And this goes on, as far as text. Again, I'm just
gonna speed this up. And I'm just going to copy
and paste from the final one. So we're looking for
heading three, copy and paste. And the same goes
for these three paragraphs. That's it, that's all
we have to do, come up with paragraph and then
copy and paste. Same goes for the rest of the two.
So another paragraph here, another set of text.
If you don't like my text, course, you can always
go with Lorem. third paragraph, and learn again,
we copy and paste the text. And then right
next to this article, we'll place another one.
And this is where we will place our form. And
effectively, we're looking for form class, as
well as the contact form. So this is where we'll
add a little bit more styling. And this is what
you should see on the screen. Now I will remove
the action because of course, it's not going to be
dynamic, not going to be a working form.
And then third, we're going to go with
form row. And then I want to add the label, as
well as the input. So we'll go here with label,
as far as the poor attribute will go here
with name, I want to add a class of form,
hyphen label, again, this is coming from global
CSS, and then we'll just add your name, Ron,
we'll save it. And after that, I'm going
to go with input, a type will be text,
we're just set up a name is equal to name. And
then we want to go with ID as well as the class
of form input. So let's set it up over here,
not say ID, and I'll set that one equal to nine.
So just make sure that both attributes, the
ID and four have the same value. And we'll
also look for the class. And that will be form
input. And once I have my first row, essentially,
what we want to do is just add a comment. And
we'll say, single form row, also added over here,
the end of my div, and also end up single row.
And now of course, we just want to copy and paste,
I believe two more times. I mean, this is
going to be text area, so maybe you only want.
So let's take this one, copy and paste. And as
far as the values, essentially everywhere where
we have the name, we want to change it around to
email showed me select all the names over here.
I'll go for email, and the only one that I
need change back, of course, is this one.
So say name is also equal to an email. So if I
take a look, yep, there it is. Now, of course,
we still need to add some CSS, but at least
the basic setup is working. And like I said,
we'll also add a text area. So let me keep on
scrolling here. And after this row, we'll set up
another one. The class is exactly the same. So go
here with form row. And then inside of it. Again,
another label. In this case we're looking for
a message class will still be a form our label.
As far as the text, let's just write message and
this is where we want to go With that text area,
so right after this label will go with text area.
And as far as the attribute values, let's set up
both name and ID equal to a message. And then I'll
remove the columns and rows, because of course,
we have already all the styling in a global CSS,
so go with form, we're looking forward to class of
text area. And once we save, we only need to add
a button. So right after this Dev, we'll go with
button. Now in this case, it's going to be type
Submit. And now as far as the styling will go with
btn, btn iphon block. Now, of course, the button
is going to be spanning all across our form.
And line as far as the text messages go with
sub. And once we have all of this in place,
essentially, we just want to navigate to main CSS.
Sure, let me open up the file for CSS and working
for main CSS, I have the about think I need to
copy the comment as well copy and paste. And of
course, now I'm looking for the contact page.
First the value contact page. And I'll close
the sidebar here. And what I want to do is set
up that form to be 100%. Remember, by default,
we have some value already on the forum class.
And that's why we added that contact form class.
And in here, let's just say width to be our
percent. And as far as the margin, I'm going to go
with zero. Now the word of course, will use the
container, the contract container to set them up
side by side. And in fact, we'll do that right
now. where we want to go back through the main
CSS, we want to look for contact and learn hyphen
container. And here we'll go with display grid.
Now again, on the small screen, by default, it's
going to be a one column layout. But that doesn't
stop us from setting up the properties for the
gap. So to REM reorients. Over here for the
column, a man I'll also add a padding to the
bottom markers. And we're gonna go with three
RPMs. So that's gonna be the distance in between
these guys. And once we have all of this in place,
Now, of course, we just want to worry about
the media. And we'll go with Meteor screen.
As far as the min width, one, we'll
just set it up as 992 min width 992
pixels. Of course, I'm here, let's just go with
contact container. And I'm going to be looking for
grid template columns. And in this case, I'm going
to go with one fraction. So that's for the text,
that's for the left column over here. And as far
as the form, I'm actually going to hard code,
I'm going to say 450 pixels. And then since
I want text in the center, again, I'm going
to go with that align items center. So let's go
back over here on line items. And we'll set it
equal to center. And of course, once we have
added the CSS, we're done with the contact form,
now we can focus on our next task. And
once we have the contact form in place,
Now, of course, let's set up the tags page, the
moment has only a heading one. And what we're
shooting for is this look where we have the tags.
Of course, these are going to be dynamic in normal
project. But in our case, we'll just hard code.
And once you click on a tag, when you navigate
that tag template page, and of course, this page
we already have, that's why we have the recipes
in place. And as part of the setup Well, here, let
me go back to the tags. And I'll do the same here.
And of course, I'm already in the page,
so I'm good. We're looking for tags, HTML,
close the sidebar For now, we want to remove that
heading one will still keep the page. What we're
looking for is the section. And I'm going to go
with tags wrapper. So that's the class in here.
Let's add a comment. So single Montag, and I'm
just because it's going to be under single tag
and optional tag. And then as far as the setup,
it's going to be a link class will be a tag.
And again, we'll hard code these values. And I'm
not going to go over why we're hard coding values,
because I believe I have said that already more
than enough times during this project where
you want this link to navigate well, to the tag
template. Remember, that represents some specific
tag and recipes that have that tag. And as far
as the proper path. Well, it is tagged template
HTML. Correct. Like I said, we'll add a class over
here, and I'll say tag, and as far as the values,
we'll just go with heading five We'll set it equal
to beef. And as far as the mana recipes, well,
it's going to be a paragraph with one recipe. And
now what we want to do is just take this one tag,
copy and paste, let me take a look how many are
created, think I went with five, suddenly see,
the moment I have 1234 showed me copy that one
more time. And now we're just want to change
these routers, we're gonna, this is gonna
have two recipes. And we have dinner, food,
and all that. So let me scroll up, let me make
sure that I don't do anything with the first
one. Okay, that one stays the same. For the second
one, we're looking for breakfast, it's gonna have
two recipes. Then we have one for carrots. And
that is going to have, I believe three recipes.
Then we have dinner and food. We have one recipe
for dinner with foresters, online food with one
wants, the HTML is in place. Now, of course, let's
just navigate to main CSS. And we want to set up
another new comment in here. So go here with tags,
of course, this one a little bit more serious as
of the contact page, because, of course, we're the
contact page, the biggest one was the form. But
we already had bunch of styles in a global CSS. So
let's go here with tags page. And then I'm going
to worry about my wrapper, again, is going to be a
one column layout, starting with the small screen.
And as the screen size increases, then we'll
also change the amount of columns. But that
doesn't stop us from tags wrapper. So that's the
entire wrapper. When we go with display grid,
I'm going to go with qR M. So that's going to
be for the columns and rows, and adding the same
deal. We'll go with padding bottom three are
yums. And once we have all our lists in place,
now of course, we just want to worry about that
one single tag. And we will set up the CSS is
going to be following where we'll target the tag,
we're looking for background. And in this case,
I'm going to go with gray, and 500. That's going
to be the default value, then I also want to add
right away a border radius. And of course, we'll
use our CSS variable for that. After that we want
to go text align center. So make sure that
the text is in the center color, white thing
that should look good. And as far as transition,
while we're just use our CSS variable, because
when we'll hover, I'll change this color. And
then we're pretty much done, I just want to set
up the padding top bottom, zero point 75, REM, and
left and right zero. As I'm hovering over the tag,
like I said, I want to change it to
a primary color, religious grab the
background one person over here, and instead
of gray 500, we'll go with primary 571.
Notice as we're hovering Now, of course, we're
changing the color, and we just want to add some
margins, zero to the bottom of heading five,
paragraph because if you remember, the default,
we have them there. So now of course we'll remove
those margins. And I want to do for both for tag
paragraph as well as the heading. So therefore
we'll go with tag paragraph tag heading. And
then like I said, we're gonna go with margin
bottom zero, so both of them have no margin.
They're also I want to increase the font weight
for the heading. So let's set up the hearing here.
We're going to go with font weight. And let's just
set it up as 600. Let's save as you can see, now
of course, the font weight is a little bit bolder.
And lastly, we'll have to Commonwealth starting
with 576. And a three column layout. Once we get
to nine or 92. Since I want to save a little bit
of time on a boilerplate, we'll just copy and
paste, set it up over here 576 we're targeting
a tags wrapper, of course. So the classes, tags
and wrapper. Since we already have display grid,
we're just going to go with grid template columns.
one fraction, one fraction. Of course, the only
thing that's left to do is to take this copy and
paste 992 and then we'll have three Commonwealth
shows because some people probably are annoyed and
we're going to go repeat. We're just say three,
one production. So of course that is the
alternative syntax that we can use. Now let
me navigate to the big screen for tags. route
is going to be my layout Once I click on a tag,
navigate to a tag template page, and with this
in place, we're really need to worry about that
single recipe page, this one over here. And don't
freak out about this error page. Essentially,
when I was setting up the structure for all
the pages, I just forgot to change it to a
single recipe. If you take a look at the title, of
course, it says single recipe. And as far as the
single recipe page, it's gonna look something like
this, we're back in home. And we just click on one
of the recipes. Again, we're hard coding these
values, there's going to be four banana package.
Stop, we have some kind of info. And
then we have instructions, ingredients,
and tools. And in order to make it easier, again,
we'll separate these two, were in the first video,
or worry about all the info section. And then
we'll deal with instructions ingredients.
And we'll start by navigating to single recipe of
course, in here, first, I want to remove that one,
we're not gonna use that anymore, the
layout is going to be following or again,
we have the page. So this is where we'll place
all of our content. And instead of the recipe page
are going to be two sections. One is going to
be recipe hero section with a class of recipe
and hyphen hero. And then the second one will
be the recipe content. So that's where the
instructions tools and all that is going to go in.
So we're going to go here with recipe content. And
this is the one that we'll work on in the next
video. And this video will focus on this one,
I'll start by placing some kind of image
like I said, we are hard coding this.
So we're simply needs to look for the assets. And
then more specifically image we want and Marcos,
since I'm going with banana pancakes,
I'm going to go with recipe number five,
I do want to add some classes here. So we'll
start with our image class. And there's also
going to be a recipe hyphen, hero, and
hyphen IMG. As far as the alternative,
let's just say bank x, once we save, we should
see the image, which is always a good sign right
next to the image, we'll have that second
layout. And this is going to be the article,
sort of the articles start with heading two. And
we're just write the names of banana pancakes.
And after that, we want to set up some
kind of dummy text. And in this case,
I'm going to go with paragraph and of course,
like I did before, I'm just gonna grab my
hipster text, copy and paste my text. Awesome.
And we'll have a recipe icons. So of course,
we're talking about this column over here. And
the same goes for tags. And I guess more properly,
this is a row with a three column layout. Well, of
course, we have the icons. And then here we have
another row where we display the tags. So let's
keep scrolling. As far as the recipe icons, well,
we want to go with they've sort of
they've set up some articles. Again,
we're not placing in the recipe content.
So let's just add here a comment recipe
content. So we're clear where we're setting
this up. So we want to look for recipe hero.
And then right off to the paragraph, we'll go
with Dev, and we'll just say recipe, icons,
we'll copy and paste. And of course, the moment
I'm just setting up the comment, but eventually
the dev is going to be there. And the second one
will be recipe tags. And this is very useful. Once
you start troubleshooting. Trust me, adding these
comments seems like a silly idea. But once in a
while, it really helps you out. And then we'll
look for them. And like I said, we'll be looking
for a recipe icons inside of it, we're going to go
with one article. And that is going to be a single
recipe icon. As far as the setup, well, we just
need to look for the icon, and therefore I'll go
for element. The classes are following FA s and
FA Clark, a man would just add some kind of dummy
text that's going to be placed in the heading five
or say prep time. And also we'll have a paragraph
with some kind of hard coded value. In this case,
that's going to be 30 minutes. And now of course,
I just want to take this article, copy
and paste and change some values around
where the second one will be f A are not
FA s FA are not going to be a prep time.
Gonna be a cook time. Here, I'm just gonna go
with 15 minutes. And then lastly, we have the user
friends. So that's the name of the icon. We're
looking for FA s fa. And let's remove this piece
and let's say user Friends, this is just going to
be amount of servings, servings. And we're looking
for some kind of value again. So in this case,
I'm going to go with six servings. And lastly,
we want to set up those tags. So again, make sure
that you don't place this in the recipe icons,
make sure that you place here in the recipe tags.
So there will the class of recipe tags. And as far
as the content here, we'll go with tags. So that's
text. And this is going to be a link. Now again,
we're navigating to a tag template page, therefore
in my href, doctype, tag, template, and HTML, and
we just want to set up some dummy values. So beef,
save it, now you want to take the link. So don't
think tags tag just don't link, I think I'm going
to copy and paste this, I don't know two more
times. So three total. Let me close the sidebar,
we just want to change these powers around.
second one will be breakfast. Third one will
be pancakes. And the fourth one will be food.
Once we have the HTML for to hear on voice, Now,
of course, let's just navigate to main CSS, we're
looking for the last thing pretty much all the
way in the bottom, we'll have our recipe template.
So let's take this comment, copy and paste. And
we'll just say, a recipe. template or single
recipe, you're not actually I'm gonna go with
single recipe, single recipe page. And we want
to start with that recipe hero. So recipe hero,
by default is going to be a one column layout.
And we'll right away, set it up as display grid
should be already familiar with that. All right
away also set up the gap to be through your items.
Once I have this in place, now I want to focus on
that image. And remember the class was a recipe
hero, IMG, recipe Hero, Hero IMG. Basically I want
to go with height to be 300 pixels. So now it's
a little bit bigger. As far as the border radius,
well, we have the property for that we have border
radius property, when it comes to the paragraph,
this one over here, I'm just gonna make it
a little bit lighter as far as gray color.
So therefore, I'll go with recipe info. And then
I'm looking for paragraph. And of course, we want
to go with color. And I'm looking for gray. And
I'm going to go with 600. So now it's a little bit
later, then we can start focusing on those icons.
So that's the next row. As far as the setup there,
we'll go with a recipe. I can't, man, I'm looking
for display grid, sure, I want to set up as a grid
layout. And right from the get go, it's going to
be a three column while so go over here with grid
template columns. And in this case, I'm going to
go to repeat. And as far as the value, I'll repeat
three times, and one fraction. So right from the
get go, we have a three column layout. And again,
I've massively zoomed in. So of course,
normally it's going to look something like this.
And then once we have all of this in place. Now
let's add a little bit of gap. And in my case,
I'm going to go to one REM and we do want to
add a margin top bottom, and therefore I'm going
to go with two REM and zero, so nothing on left
and right. And when it comes to the text align,
I want to place it in the center. So let's set up
here text align center. When we want to focus on
the icon, we can access that by recipe icons. So
recipe hyphen, icons, and I'm looking for Ireland.
And here I'm going to go with font
size 1.5 RPMs. And as far as the color,
let's just go with primary color. And we're going
to be looking for our primary one. And I believe
I'm going to go with 500. Why don't we want to
target the heading five as well as the paragraph.
And in this case, I think it's going
to be faster if I just copy and paste.
So we're looking forward to heading five. And
we're also looking for the paragraph, or we
just want to set up the margin bottom to be equal
to zero. And then font size to be zero point 85.
REM, let's say well one. And lastly, I want to
target this recipe icons paragraph and just add
a different color. And in this case, I'm going
to go for gray. And again, I'm looking forward
at 600 value. So let's go here. And let's say
600. So that's going to be the color for that
paragraph. Man, we just really need to worry about
those tags, as well as the two column layout once
we get to the big screen. And in order to style
the tags. We'll start With the actual container,
and we'll set it up as display flex. So right from
the get go, we're going to be display flex, a man
will align them in the center vertically. So align
items center around, we'll make sure that it wraps
if the screen size is not big enough, so flex
wrap equal to rub a man as far as the font size,
I'm going to go with 0.7. This is the interesting
part, where I'm going to be looking for em values.
So basically, depending on my container, I also
want to add the font weight. And in this case,
it's going to be equal to 600. So the font weight,
of course, is going to be a little bit bigger.
And then let's target those links. So of
course, I'm not talking about that text,
talking about the link. So recipe tags, and we're
looking for a element and background will be equal
to the primary 500. So primary hyphen, hyphen,
primary 500. And as far as the border radius,
or not border bottom, sorry, border radius, that's
going to be equal to a border radius CSS variable,
then we want to set up some kind of color, that's
going to be equal to white. And man as far as the
padding top is actually going to be quite
small. So 0.05 REM, as far as left and right,
we're going to go with 0.5 REM. And then
we also want to add a little bit of margin,
we're not going to go with top bottom, so that's
why it's going to be zero, but left and right
is going to be zero point 25. REM, then we want
to go with text transform. And we'll capitalize
text transform on couplers. Lastly, like I said,
we want to worry about that to Commonwealth once
we get to the big screen. Since I'm lazy, typing
the media queries, let me just select this code,
copy and paste. And we just need to change some
of ours around where the men will still be 992.
So that's the same point in here, we want to go to
a recipe hyphen hero. Once we get the big screen,
I just want to change it to two column layout.
As far as the image is going to be for fractions.
When it comes to the text, as well as the icons
and all that it's going to be five fractions.
And again, since I want both of them to be in
center, we're just going to go with align items
in the center since the height for one
of them probably is going to be bigger.
If we go to the next one. Notice now in this
case, the image is the one that it's smaller
on a big screen, therefore, it's sitting
right in the center. So that's the look
that we have for hero. Beautiful Congrats,
we have finally arrived at the last step.
And essentially in here, we want to set up the
instructions, ingredients, tools. But before we
do that, there's actually a tiny typo here are
noticed the recipe info, it's not a recipe info
should be recipe hero. Now, of course, my text is
gray. Essentially, I'm looking here for 600. Now,
everything is just like in the final project,
I will start in a single recipe. And you're not
in this case, I'll collapse the hero. Sure, sir,
not in a way. We're looking for recipe content.
That's the one we want to set up. And here we
have two Commonwealth wherefor inside of this
section First, I want to set up that article.
And then there's going to be another article.
And since I was lazy, as far as the class names,
I just set it up as second column. That's it. So
I'm here in the second column. This is where we'll
place the ingredients and tools. But first, we'll
worry about the instructions. Some instructions,
of course, are going to go in our first column.
And I want to start with heading four. And we'll
just say instructions, when we'll set up a single
instruction comment. And after that, let's go with
deal with the same class. So single instruction.
Now inside of the div. If you take a look at the
complete project, you'll notice this step on the
horizontal line. So that's going to be in our
header. And then we'll have some kind of text.
So let me start by getting this text here,
just because I want to speed this up. So first,
I'm going to set up the paragraph. But above
the paragraph, there's going to be a header.
And inside of it, we'll have another
paragraph. And I'm going to go with
step one. And then right next to it,
we want to place a empty div. And yes,
there's there needs to be here. Now there's a
million different ways how we can set it up. But
in this case, I just went with extra HTML element.
Once I have this single instruction, I just want
to copy and paste and let me take a look at this.
If I have three, so let me just copy and paste
One, two, when we want to change the step, this
is going to be two, this is going to be three,
just to stay consistent. Also take this text
and add in step number two. And same thing
for step number three, of course, you can keep
all of them the same, it doesn't really matter
which service. Okay, so I have step 123.
And then inside of the second column,
this is where we want to set up the ingredients.
And we also want to go with those. Now both of
them are going to be in separate Dev. So let's go
with dev Saturday, we're going to go with heading
for an ingredient. Hopefully, I can spell it
correctly, because that's usually an issue.
And we're just looking for paragraph,
a class of single ingredient.
And then as far as the value again, yes, I know
that it's probably annoying to some people. But
we'll just copy and paste. Since I don't see the
point of setting up everything from the scratch.
What you want to do is just take this paragraph,
so not the heading for just a paragraph from the
same class, you probably want to copy and paste
at least in my case, I'm going to copy and paste
this two times. And we just want to change these
vowels around. So we want to select this one,
we want to do the same thing for the third one
as well. And then the same goes for the tools.
But of course, the difference is the class name,
as well as the text. So we can copy and paste
or we can set up everything from scratch.
In this case, I think I'm going to go with
setting up everything from scratch. So Dev, Van
heading for tools. And let's go with paragraph.
Let's add a class here. So class, I'm more looking
for a single tool. And as far as the value again,
Mark, just take these ones, copy and paste the
first tool, I'm just going to copy and paste
and essentially get those values once we
have the HTML. Now let's navigate to main
CSS. And let's continue over here. First, we'll
worry about the recipe content. Now, of course,
I'm talking about the container where both the
instructions, ingredients and tools are sitting,
because we'll have to Commonwealth. So let's
go here with recipe, recipe hyphen content.
And we're going to be looking for a padding, top
bottom, three, REM and then left and right zero
whenever we want to go with display grid. So
that's, of course, our small screen layout.
And we'll set it up as gap to our games for the
rows and firearms for the columns. But of course,
we only have the rows on a small screen. And then
let's go with a media query. And if you want, you
can add it here as well just make sure that you
move this media query below the recipe counted.
Otherwise, there's going to be a mess up, you
know, in my case, just stay consistent. I'm just
going to copy it and paste. And we're looking for
recipe content, I want to go with grid template
columns. And as far as the values will go with
two fractions, so that's for the first column.
That's for instructions, and then one fraction for
the other value. Now if we go to the big screen,
check it out, we have the instructions, as well
as ingredients and tools in a second column. And
then slowly but surely, let's start working
on those instructions. So we're looking for
single instruction. And first, I want to go
with header. And this is going to be a display
grid. So now of course I'm dealing with this
step, the horizontal line that we cannot see,
as far as the setup is going to be grid template
columns. We're looking for auto, one fraction,
show the step will have its height, or I'm
sorry, its width, and the horizontal line
is going to take up the rest. I also want to
add a little bit of gap here. I'm going to go
1.5 RPMs. And what's that one that horizontal
line in the center? We're going to go with a
line items on center. Sir, it the reason why
we don't see anything is because we haven't
styled that horizontal line. So why don't we do
that? First, let's go with single instruction
when we're looking for the header, and then
more specifically a div. And here, let's go
with height, two pixels. And background will be
a gray one. And I think I'm going to go with that
300 we have our single recipe. That's good. And we
also have that horizontal line. Now there's still
some things we need to add. Don't worry about it.
As long as you can see this horizontal line. That
means that we are moving in the right direction.
And I'm going to hop back to the header and more
specifically, the paragraph. So we're living
A single instruction van will import a header.
And instead of the day, we're looking for the
paragraph. And in this case, I want to go with
text transform, and set it up as uppercase. Now,
of course, we're dealing with that step one, two,
and three, then let's go with font weight.
And we'll set it up as 600. Gray. And let's
add right away a margin bottom to be zero, margin
bottom, zero, and I also want to change the color.
And I'll set it up as primary. And once we save
everything works, lastly, when it comes to the
instruction, so this one over here, I want to set
up a different, Great North target that since I
don't want to select this paragraph over here,
I'm just gonna say, single, single instruction,
one error, and I'm just targeting the paragraph.
And you're not actually need to remove this error,
my bad. So basically, I'm looking for the
entire paragraph, therefore algos single
instruction. And only the direct child of
that instruction, which is the paragraph
will have that color and gray. So go here with
color. And for gray. I think I'm going to go with
seminar. Now, of course, this one is a little bit
lighter. If you don't believe me, can actually
send this up as 300. And you will clearly
see that I'm targeting the correct paragraph
when we want to style the second column. So
let's keep moving, we'll say second column.
And in this case, there's not much to it, we'll
say display grid, we're looking for grid in this
case. Now I do want to add a program, that's
going to be equal to two RPMs. So that's the
distance in between. and knowledge just started
the single ingredient, as well as single tool.
Now when it comes to single ingredient may
again make sure that I spell this correctly.
I'm looking for a border bottom border bottom.
Now it's going to be two pixels solid. And we're
looking for two gray one. So let's set up here
var and then we're looking for gray, and then
300. That's going to be the border. I also want
to add a little bit of padding in the bottom,
padding bottom zero point 75 RPMs and nine as far
as the color, I'm going to go with that gray 700.
And, same goes for single tool, single tool in
here. We'll go with the same border, show copy
and paste. Same goes for padding. So pretty much
the same stuff. Just the colors are going to be
different, where I'm going to go the color for
my primary 500 and then as far as text, I just
want to capitalize, so text transform, set it up
as capitalized. And once all of this is in place,
we're done with the project. Congratulations.
And I hope to see you in the next one.